دول هشه حدود متلاشيه فساد مستشعر مع
انقلابات عسكريه لم يجد داعش بيئه اكثر
مثاليه بعد سقوط مركزيته في الرقه السوريه
والموصل العراقيه لاعاده احياء مشروع
دولته الارهابيه هنا افريقيا 20 دوله على
الاقل تشهد نشاطا مباشرا للتنظيم اخرى
تستخدم للخدمات اللوجستيه اضافه الى حشد
الاموال والموارد وفره تتسع خريطه داعش
بفضل الفروع اكثر من 20 فرعا داخل القاره
السمراء وابرزها هو تحالف الديمقراطيه
تنشط في اوغندا وانتقلت بعض الخلاياها عبر
الحدود الى
جمهوريه الكونغو حركته الشباب موزمبيقيه
او ما تعرف بانصار السنه والجماعه احدث
تحديدا الارهابيا للاستقرار في الشرق
افريقيا
على تنفيذ العديد من العمليات خاصه وسط
افريقيا فرع يصل عدد عناصر الى 1,100
يعتمد في التجنيد على السكان المحليين كما
ينشط استقطابه للشباب من تنزانيا وجزر
القمر جماعه اخرى بايعت داعش بعد انشقاقها
عن تنظيمات اخرى كبكو حرام ان هجريه وحركه
الشباب الصوماليه وانصار الدين والتوحيد
والجهاد في غرب افريقيا ينعكس نشاط هذه
الجماعات بالنصق التصاعدي للعنف
والتفجيرات في دول الساحل نيجيريا النيجر
مالي وبوركينا فاسو وصولا الى حوض ابو
حيره تشاد كما ينعكس على الاقتتال مع
القاعده تحديدا منذ مارس العام الماضي بعد
ايام من اعلان فرنسا الانسحاب من مائلي
تحرك داعش للسيطره على مناطق نفوذ القاعده
من شرق الاراضي الماليه على الحدود مع
النيجر لي يستحكم من بعض المناطق في
تحياتي مليكه واخرى باتجاه قوي وبالطبعه
الصومال حيث تلقى التنظيم احدث الضربات
بمصر زعيم التنظيم ابو البراء الاماني قبل
ايام بولايه بوتلاند
اضعاف ما حصل وما يمكن ان يحصل عليه داعش
في سوريا والعراقيه يجده في افريقيا مناجم
ذهب فحم حقول الغاز بريقوا الذهب مغرم في
مالك ثلاث اغنى دوله افريقيه بالمعدن
النفيس ترك الانسحاب الفرنسي منها فراغا
يحرس التنظيم بالتنافس مع جماعه
ولذلك عين داعش على ولاتينا وبالفعل
السيطره التنظيم وعدوه اللدود القاعده
لجماعته نصره الاسلام والمسلمين على مناطق
حدوديات يسهل تهريب المعادن عبرها
ويهجرون السكان لتسهيل التنقيب لمعان
الناس في جنوب افريقيا التي يمثل المسلمون
اثنين 100 جذب التنظيم اليها خاصه في
بروتوريا لكنه اكثر الوضوحا في موزمبيق
حيث ادت الحملات الوحشيه التي شنها فرع
اهل السنه والجماعه الى مقتل اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف شخص وتشريد حوالي مليون شخص
وتهديد استثمارات الغاز بمليرات الدولارات